i i have a lot of things that i've
forgotten that i can't remember
for instance i can go back to my
childhood and stuff and i still remember
that but yet you can i can go into the
70s
and there are a lot of things i can't
remember the same thing with the victims
i've looked at all of
i don't know if if you notice here we
got pictures of every one of the victims
here and
believe it or not for the last 12 years
i've studied these photos of the victims
and there is no
we we have a shot of all of the victims
together here
and when you look over to the photos i
have no recollection of any of them
never met them
and we've gone over this more than once
they're just names and faces
and when you when you look at them
the thing of it is we took it a step
further we went into their backgrounds i
wanted to know where they were at
what schools they attended who they hung
out with
and what kind of activities they were
into and that's what we dug up on each
one of the victims
but still there is no association
none of them never worked for me none of
them they never went to any places that
i ever hung around because i didn't
hang around that many places unless
you're involved in politics
or you if you were involved in clowning
then i might have ran into you
but there's no way i could have run into
any of them
you